the African Kingdom of the home is at a
Crossroads a new King
has just taken power their enemy the Oyo
Empire has joined forces with the Mahi
people to raid the home Villages and
sell their captives to European slavers
an evil trade that has pulled both
Nations into a vicious circle
powerful or you have new Guns and Horses
but the young king has his own there's
some weapon an Elite Force of female
soldiers
led by a general naniska
now these Warriors are all that stand
between the oil and the homies
annihilation
welcome
to bed
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa
come on
stupid
all right
where are they prisoners where are our
people we are farmers we took no one
you will be home soon
thank you
what's this
that can only mean all your soldiers
who is she
foreign
we will take you back to your village
perhaps your father
[Music]
the prisoners are ready to match
bring me
stuff
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
it doesn't matter now yeah tell your
mother to see me for the dress
more dress
your wedding dress I will make you
beautiful
tell her they have made you another
match I don't know what she's talking
about
they are coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
but I want to see
King does not allow us to look upon
their Good Year
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
they are here for you
they do not know an evil is coming
I wish to speak to the king his only
thing wise today tell him I will wait